c'est non non le courroux de l'état et
pas le gourou de lectra le cours de
l'état pierre desforges procureur
général de la république française
alala marie c'est là je ne sais pas
pourquoi cette mélodie me fait penser à
chaud eh bien monsieur le président oui
monsieur le chanteur polyglotte cynique
de gauche
le public pourri dieu m'est témoin que
je ne suis pas xénophobe
je dirais même que la xénophobie m'est
étrangère
si je puis me permettre cette délicieuse
boutade qui j'en suis sûr ne fera
sourire que moi
pourtant c'est très curieux mais j'ai
beau ne pas être xénophobe je ne peux
pas encadrer les néerlandais par exemple
dans ma vie amoureuse extrêmement
tumultueuse et mouvementée j'ai eu des
liaisons avec des belges sd suisse oise
des états unienne damon à corte d italie
les espagnols est et même des mexicains
mais jamais jamais au grand jamais je
n'ai cherché la moindre idylle avec une
hollandaise
si une fois cependant c'était au début
des années 70 amsterdam au printemps
l'air encore fred avril mettait du rouge
aux pommettes des coûts du plan b dont
les seins ronds détendre jouer librement
dans les corsages de soie blanche s'est
quittés quartier cricket un émoi bien
raide et bien droite
ouais la tour ouais c'est pas d'idée car
ces manuels jeu reprend là où j'ai été
coupé bien raide et bien droite
la tour de la monnaie dressait sa pointe
a redit au dessus du canal dont les au
morne et glauque allait se jeter dans le
danube éternelle où les fiers gondolier
ansari nationale en tonnes de leurs voix
profonde le troublant sirtaki
septentrionale qui chante la détresse et
perdu des joyeux moissonneurs de tulipes
aux hormones
c'est alors que je la vie douce suave
timide 1 m 97 mais rien que du musée
elle était née à amsterdam et venait de
faire une courte carrière de starlettes
à tunis elle était divine greta gourbis
s'appelait greta gourbis en effet
c'était pas son vrai nom son vrai nom
s'était greta la fiente se faisait
appeler greta gourbis pour faire plus
flics d'ailleurs vous savez peut-être
pas mais la plupart des acteurs sont un
peu mégalomane et prétentieux comme l'a
dit leur dave
il pense par exemple à michel michel
lafleur qui se fait appeler michel
bouquet parce qu'il y en a plus c'est
vrai c'est comme patrick de plastique
qui se fait appeler patrick dewaere
parce que c'est plus chic illégalement
il y avait même simone signoret c'est
pas son vrai nom c'est simone 3 n'y
aurait sans vraiment les choses simone
je suis sûr qu'elle écoute et claude
patois ah bon non mais claude brasseur
c'est claude bibine faut pas se leurrer
c'est catherine de vieilles qui me l'a
dit catherine deneuve qui me l'a dit au
cours d'un dîner chez alain de cours
puis alain delon durée c'est pas la
longueur qui compte si l'on en croit les
membres de l'académie
ça me rappelle une très belle histoire
d'une haute teneur littéraire et d'une
grande portée philosophique
alors là c'est un type qui entre dans
une pharmacie eddy bonjour monsieur
l'apothicaire je voudrais une gabardine
britannique alors
bon alors voir pouf pouf et fera pas
excusez moi mais ce président je vois je
m'égare du nord d'où vient notre accusés
et où en étais-je donc peut-être
peut-être serait-il bon qu'après cette
intéressante digression dans
l'étymologie patronymique tu peux
continuer à dormir c'est du grec
nous sommes peut-être banque de
retrouvions ensemble fil conducteur de
ma pensée alors qu'est ce que je disais
le plus simple c'est peut-être que je
fasse un résumé des chapitres précédents
comme cela se pratique dans les
feuilletons radiodiffusé que les
paralytiques écoute sur france culture
we've les paralytiques parce que les
autres tourner le bouton les résumés les
chapitres précédents du genre josiane
belle infirmière a quitté son mari léon
de saint tite rhône
elle était perdue menthe amoureuse de
guy de saint luc le brillant avocat non
pas toi briand dont la soeur gloria
n'être autre que la maîtresse de jacques
de saint chance elle perd de sheila
mongolia de sa chance elle lors d'un bal
masqué au château louis xiii clés en
mains des saints chancel josiane fait la
connaissance d'un jeune étudiant honnête
mais pauvre gonzague saint pognon dont
le père le général charles sus mes
preuves de symphonia consolât depuis la
mort de sa chère épouse la pieuse et
fidèle thérèse de la paire de seins
pognon trop vite arraché à l'affection
des siens dans sa 76e année à la suite
d'une longue et cruelle maladie à peine
en deux une messe du souvenir aura lieu
dimanche à 11h à saint-honoré dès lors
on peut apporter son manger là le
général symphonia le général ça peut
nous on qui mourut pendant la guerre
d'algérie sous les balles d'un fellaghas
de type nord africain restera un soir
que josiane belle infirmière était
rentré très tard de l'hôpital où elle
avait fait des heures supplémentaires
sous le bureau du docteur la mort lente
le sympathique cancérologue de la télé
quelle ne fut pas sa surprise quand on
sans lui ce patois la porte elle
découvrit guilde saint-luc sécher la
mongolia dans une position qui ne
prêtaient à aucune équivoque
en effet ils mangeaient des nouilles
vivant gel bien sûr en écoutant le jeu
des mille francs c'est la gerbe
c'est la gerbe de bailleul qui a pris à
la jeune fille son infortune bord et
c'est donc donc d'avé coupable mais
pourquoi ne puis-je encadrer les
néerlandais je vous comptez il y un
instant avec quel brio mon en idylle
avec greta gourbis ma copine d'amsterdam
certes mesdames et messieurs les jurés
juste pu aimer cette belle hollandaise
hélas elle fumait du haschich et j'ai un
principe de morale très strictes
auxquelles je tiens par dessus tout je
n'ai jamais eu de liaison avec des
filles qui fument du haschich
car la seule odeur de ses terres
maudites brise mes élans sexuels les
plus fous d'ailleurs je l' ai appris et
vous aussi mesdames et messieurs les
jurés je vous l'avais appris à l'école
il ya fort longtemps
on ne doit jamais faire de liaison en
présence de h aspiré
c'est pourquoi il a écrit sassou
incident
c'est pourquoi on dit des hollandaises
des hollandaises et non pas des
hollandaises
alors qu'on dit des haricots des ebooks
des hernies discales des bassins
houillers etc etc comme l'exigent
l'harmonie de l'art histoire de la
grammaire française à qui je rends ici
un vibrant hommage de rolande bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que non